for what purpose does the gentlelady
from illinois seek recognition
designated by mr rush pursuant to hres
965.
i inform the house that mr rush will
vote yes on the motion to concur
uh
this
hello
the motion is adopted without objection
emotional reconsider is laid on the
table
pursuant to clause 8 of rule 20 the
unfinished business
is the vote on ordering the previous
question on house resolution 1164
on which the yeas and nays are ordered
the kirk will report the title of the
resolution
house calendar number 96 house
resolution 1164.
resolution provided for consideration of
the resolution house resolution 1153
condemning unwanted unnecessary medical
procedures on individuals without their
full
informed consent and provided for
consideration
of the resolution house resolution
eleven fifty four
condemning q anon and rejecting the
conspiracy theories it promotes
the question is on ordering the previous
question
members will record their votes by
electronic device
purpose is this gentleman from
california seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms chu of california
pursuant to house resolution 965
i informed the house that ms chu will
vote
yes on the previous question
purposes does the gentle lady from
california seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
representative fudge pursuant to hres
965 i inform the house that
representative fudge
will vote i on the previous question
for what reason does the gentleman from
the commonwealth of virginia seek
recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
miss dina titus
of nevada pursuant hres965
i inform the house that miss titus will
vote yes
on the previous question
purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition mr speaker
is the member designated by miss roy
bell allard pursuant to house resolution
965. i informed the house that miss
robel allard
will vote yes on the previous question
purpose says the gentlelady from
delaware seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr get of colorado
pursuant to h hres 965 i informed the
house that mr get will vote yes
on the previous question
purposes does the gentleman from
illinois seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr grijalva of arizona pursuant to hres
965
i inform the house that mr grijalva will
vote yey on the previous question
purposes does the gentleman from
michigan seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr huffman of california pursuant
to hres 965 i inform the house that mr
huffman
will vote yes on the previous question
as the member designated by mr thompson
of california pursuant to atres 965
i informed the house that mr thompson
will vote yes on the previous question
as the member designated by mr
butterfield of north carolina
pursuant to hres 965 i inform the house
that mr butterfield
will vote yes on the previous question
purpose does the gentleman from new york
see recognition
uh as the member designated by
chairwoman zoloft and pursuant to hres
965 i informed the house
that chairwoman lofgren will vote yay
on the previous question is the member
designated by
chairwoman eddie bernice johnson
pursuant to hres 965 i informed the
house
that chairman johnson will vote yay on
the previous question
is the member designated by congressman
gregory meeks
pursuant to hres 965 inform the house
that congressman meeks will vote yay
on the previous question as the member
designated by congressman jose serrano
pursuant to hres965 i inform the house
that congressman serrano
will vote yay on the previous question
for what purpose does the gentlelady
from florida seek recognition
as the member designated by ms demings
of florida pursuant to hres 965 i
informed the house that miss demings
will vote yes on the previous question
purpose does the gentlelady from the
commonwealth of massachusetts seek
recognition
thank you mr speaker as the member
designated by ms frankel pursuant to
hres
965. i inform the house that ms frankel
will vote
yes on the previous question as the
member designated by ms pingree pursuant
to hres965 i informed the house that ms
pingree will vote yes
on the previous question and as the
member designated by ms mann pursuant to
hres 965 i informed the house that ms
ming
will vote yes on the previous question
for what purposes does the gentleman
from the commonwealth of pennsylvania
seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr lawson of florida
pursued to the house resolution 965
and from the house that mr larsen votes
yes
on the previous question
for what purposes does the gentle lady
from north carolina seek recognition
speaker as the member designated by mrs
wilson of florida pursuant to housewares
965.
i informed the house that mrs wilson
will vote yes
on the previous question
for what purpose does the gentleman from
new jersey seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
miss bonnie watson coleman pursuant to
hres 965
i inform the house that miss watson
coleman will vote yes
on the previous question
purposes does the gentleman from
tennessee seek recognition
thank you mr speaker as the member
designated by mr lipinski pursuant to
hres 965 i inform the house that mr
lipinski will vote yes
on the previous question
for what purposes does the gentleman
from california seek recognition mr
speaker as member designated by
congressmember napolitano pursuant to
house resolution
965. i inform the house that mr politano
will vote yes
on the previous question
what purposes does the gentlelady seek
recognition from the commonwealth of
virginia
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr mckeach and also from the
commonwealth of virginia pursuant to
house resolution 965. i inform the house
that mr mckitchen
will vote yes on the previous question
for what purposes does the gentle lady
from the state of kansas seek
recognition
mr speaker is the member designated by
mr richmond pursuant to hres 965 i
informed the house that mr richmond will
vote i
on the previous question
for what purposes does the gentle lady
from illinois seek recognition
as the member designated by mr rush
pursuant to hres 965.
i inform the house that mr rush will
vote yes on the previous question
for what purpose does the gentleman from
the commonwealth of massachusetts seek
recognition
good evening mr speaker as the member
designated by the honorable mr james
langevin of rhode island
pursuant to house resolution 965. i'd
like to inform the house that mr
lanzavin will vote yes on the motion to
move the previous question on house
resolution 1164.
thank you
what purposes does the gentlelady from
michigan seek recognition
as the member designated by ms captor of
ohio pursuant to hres 965
i informed the house that ms captor will
vote
i on the previous question
for what purposes does the gentlelady
from the state of california seek
recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by mr
desanie
pursuant to hws 965
i informed the house that mr desonia
vote yes on the previous question
for what purposes does the gentlelady
from michigan seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by
miss
joyce beatty pursuant to hres
965. i informed the house that miss
beatty joyce beatty will vote yes on the
previous question
this is the gentleman from arizona seek
recognition
as the member designated by ms
kirkpatrick pursuant to hres 965.
i informed the house that mr patrick
will vote yes
on the previous question as the member
designated by mr gallego pursuant to
hres 965
i inform the house that mr gallego will
vote yes on the previous question
for what purpose does the gentleman from
connecticut seek recognition
mr speaker
okay uh mr speaker as the member
designated by ms johanna hayes
pursuant to house resolution 965 i
informed the house
that ms hayes will vote yes on the
previous question
for what purpose does a gentleman from
maryland seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr poken of wisconsin
pursuant to house resolution 965 i rise
to inform the house that mr poken
will vote eye on the previous question
as the member designated
by mr levin of michigan pursuing the
house resolution nine six five i
informed nasa mr levin
who will vote eye on the previous
question
purposes does the gentlelady from
florida seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms mugrachel powell of florida pursuant
to hres 965.
i informed the house and ms mukasao
powell will vote yay on the previous
question
and mr speaker as the member designated
by mr hastings of florida
pursuant to hres 965 i informed the
house that mr hastings will also vote
yay on the previous question and
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr payne of new jersey
i informed the house that mr payne will
also vote yay on the previous question
purpose is does the gentlelady from new
hampshire seek recognition
as the member designated by mr kennedy
pursuant to hres 965 i inform the house
that mr kennedy
will vote yes on the previous question
what purpose does the gentleman from the
commonwealth of virginia seek
recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms moore
pursuant to his 965 i informed the house
to ms mural vote yes on the previous
question
as the member is there mr liu pursuant
to hrs 965
and from the house to mr liu will vote
yes on the previous question
as the member dave mr lowenthal pursuant
to hres 965.
i informed how swiss alone told yes on
the previous question
for what purposes does the gentleman
from california seek recognition
as the member designated by mr garamendi
pursuant to hres 965.
from the house that mr garamendi will
vote yes on the previous question
on this boat the yeas are 226 the nays
are 187.
the previous question the previous
question is ordered the question is on
adoption of the resolution
those in waiver say i those opposed no
and the opinion of the chair of the eyes
have it
the gentlewoman from africa mr speaker
did the gentleman recognized
thank you mr speaker i call for the yeas
and nays
pursuant to section 3 of house
resolution 965 the yeas and nays are
ordered members will record their votes
by
electoral device
purpose is does the gentlelady from
california seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
representative fudge pursuant to hres
965 i inform the house the
representative fudge will vote eye
on hres 1164.
does the gentleman from connecticut seek
recognition
mr speaker the gentleman is recognized
thank you mr speaker as the member
designated by ms johanna hayes pursuant
to house resolution 965
i inform the house that mrs hayes will
vote yes on house resolution 1164.
what purpose is does the gentlelady from
new hampshire seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr kennedy pursuant to atres
965 i inform the house that mr kennedy
will vote yes
on hres 1164.
for what purposes does the gentlelady
from michigan seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by
miss joyce beatty pursuant to hrh965
i inform the house that miss george fady
will vote
yes on hres1164
this is a gentleman from the
commonwealth of pennsylvania seek
recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by mr
lawson in florida
pursuant to house resolution 965
informed
that house mrs will vote yes
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms chu of california pursuant to house
resolution 965
i informed the house that ms chu will
vote yes
on house resolution 1164.
for what purposes does the gentleman
from california seek recognition
mr speaker is the member designated by
miss robel allard pursuant to house
resolution 965.
i informed the house that mrs robel
ollard will vote yes
on house resolution 1164.
for what purpose says the general for
what purpose does the gentlelady from
the commonwealth of massachusetts seek
recognition
mr speaker is the member designated by
ms pingree pursuant to
house res 965. i inform the house that
ms pingree will vote yes on hres 1164.
it's the member designated by ms mang
pursuant to hres
965. i informed the house that miss mang
will vote yes on
hres 1164. and as the member designated
by ms frankel pursuant to hres 965 i
informed the house that ms frankel
will vote yes on hres 1164.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
as the member designated by mr garamendi
for tuning to hres 965 i inform the
house that mr garamendi will vote yes
on hres 1164.
is that illinois
vote
sorry this is does the gentleman from
illinois seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr grijalva from arizona pursuant to hrs
965 i informed the house that mr gujarat
will vote yey
on hrs 1164.
what purpose does the gentlelady from
california seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by mr
desanie pursuant to hrs 965
i'm from the house so mr desanie will
vote yes on hres 1164.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
arizona seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by
miss kirkpatrick pursuant to hres
i informed the house that ms kirkpatrick
will vote yes on hres1164
as the member designated by mr gallego
pursuant to hres 965 i informed the
house that mr gallego will vote
yes on hres 1164.
for what purpose does the distinguished
gentleman from the commonwealth of
virginia seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms
dina titus of nevada pursuant to hres965
i inform the house that miss titus will
vote yes
on hres 1164.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
maryland seek recognition
as the member designated by mr pokhan of
wisconsin pursuant to house resolution
965
and former nasa mr poken will vote eye
on hres1164
and as the member designated by mr levin
of michigan pursuant to us resolution
965
inform the house that mr levin will vote
eye on house resolution 1164.
for what purposes does the gentlelady
from delaware seeking recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr get of colorado
pursuant to h res 965 i informed the
house that mr get will vote eye
on hres 1164.
for what purpose does the gentlelady
from florida seek recognition
as the member designated by miss demings
of florida pursuant to hres 965.
i inform the house that ms demings will
vote yes on hres 1164.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
michigan seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr thompson of california pursuant to
hres 965 i informed the house that mr
thompson will vote yes
on hres 1164. as the member designated
by mr huffman of california
pursuant to hres 965 i informed the
house that mr huffman will vote yes
on atres 1164.
as the member designated by mr
butterfield of north carolina pursuant
to hres 965 i informed the house that mr
butterfield
will vote yes on hres 1164.
purposes does the gentleman from
tennessee seek recognition
mr speaker is the member designated by
mr lipinski according to hr960
i inform the house that mr lipinski will
vote yes on hres 1164.
for what reason what purpose does the
gentlelady from north carolina seek
recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms wilson of florida pursuant to house
res 965
i informed the house that miss wilson
will vote yes on house res
1164.
purpose does the gentlelady from
michigan seek recognition
as a member designated by ms captor of
ohio pursuant to hres 965 i inform the
house
that miss captor will vote i on hres
1164.
for what purpose does the gentlelady
from florida seek recognition
here as the member designated by ms
mukasel powell of florida pursuant to
hres 965.
i've informed the house that miss
mukhersel powell will vote yay on
h.r 1164. mr speaker as the member
designated by mr hastings of florida
pursuant to hres 965 i inform the house
and mr hastings will also vote yay on
atres 1164
and mr speaker as the member designated
by mr payne of new jersey
pursuant to hres 965. i inform the house
and mr payne will also vote yea
on h.r 1160 1164.
where's he from california
what purposes does the gentleman from
california seek recognition mr speaker
is member designated by congressmember
napolitano
pursuant to house resolution 965.
i informed the house that congressmember
napolitano will vote yes on house
resolution
1164.
for what purpose does the gentlelady
from the commonwealth of virginia seek
recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr mikichen pursuant to house resolution
965. i inform the house that mr
mckeachen will vote yes on house
resolution 1164.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
the commonwealth of massachusetts seek
recognition
good evening mr speaker as the member
designated by the honorable mr james
langevin of rhode island pursuant to
house resolution 965
i'd like to inform the house that mr
landon will vote yes on the passage of
house resolution 1164
which provides for consideration of the
house resolution 1153 condemning
unwanted unnecessary medical procedures
on individuals
without their full informed consent and
house resolution 1154
condemning queuing on and rejecting the
conspiracy theories
it promotes thank you
for what purposes does the gentleman
from the commonwealth of virginia seek
recognition mr speaker as the member
designated by ms
moore of wisconsin pursue with
i inform the house the biz moore will
vote yes on hres 1164
as a member designated by mr liu of
california pursuant to his 965
and form the house to mr liu will vote
yes on hres 1164
as a member designated by mr lowenthal
of california pursuant to hres 965.
and from the house to mr lowenthal we'll
vote yes on hres 1164.
for what purposes does the gentlelady
from kansas seek recognition
mr speaker is the member designated by
mr richmond pursuant to hres 965. i
informed the house that mr richard will
vote i
on hres 1164.
for what purposes does the gentleman
from new york seek recognition
remember designated by chairwoman eddie
bernice johnson pursuant to hres 965 i
inform the house
that chairwoman johnson will vote yay on
h
res 1164. mr member designated by
chairwoman zoe lofgren pursuant to hres
965 i informed the house
that chairman lofgren will vote yay on
hres 1164.
is the member designated by congressman
jose serrano pursuant to hres 965
and told the house that congressman
serrano will vote yay
on h res 1164.
it's the member designated by
congressman gregory meeks
pursuant to hres 965 i inform the house
that congressman meeks
will vote yay on hres 1164.
for what purposes does the gentleman
from new jersey seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms bonnie watson coleman pursuant to
hres 965
i informed the house that ms watson
coleman will vote yes
on house resolution 1164.
what purposes does the gentlelady from
illinois seek recognition
as the member designated by mr rush
pursuant to hres 965
i inform the house that mr rush will
vote yes on hres 1164.
thank you
b
be qualified and confirmed without delay
we applaud president trump for
fulfilling his
promise to appoint judges who will
faithfully uphold the rule of law
defend the constitution and protect the
life and liberty of every american
thanks and i yield back
for what purpose does the gentleman from
south carolina seek recognition
mr speaker i rise today to praise the
heroic actions of
heidi dries i'll ask for you ask for
unanimous consent to address the house
for one minute and revise extend my
remarks
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute mr speaker i
rise today to praise the heroic actions
of heidi dries
a jefferson award winner on july 1st
2020 heidi saved the life of a wounded
charleston county deputy
mike costanzo after deciding to stop
when she saw a crumbled human on the
ground
not only did she pull over the report
and update details
of the accident 9-1-1 heidi did what any
courageous and kind-hearted person would
do she comforted
deputy costanzo in his dire time of need
heidi held his hand kept him alert
and she did not leave his side until
medical professionals arrived
on the scene heidi and mike have
mutually agreed that they are connected
for the rest of their lives
and heidi knows that it was a higher
power that put her there
on that day i rise today to honor heidi
with the hope that she may be an expert
inspiration to us all if we find
ourselves in similar situations
i yield back for what purpose does a
gentlewoman from
north carolina seek recognition thank
you mr speaker
i ask unanimous consent to address the
house for one minute
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute
thank you mr speaker on tuesday
blake lovett a true giant not only in
the north carolina agriculture community
but in the civic community passed away
unexpectedly blake was a good friend and
to say he made a profound
impact on the wilkes county community
would be
an understatement from his time on the
wilkes
board of education to his role as the
president of conagra poultry
blake was never satisfied with the
status quo
and believed that complacency was never
an option
as chairman of the wilkes county
republican party blake
exercised the level of diligence and
grace
that was second to none to blake's
family
i pray that god will continue to bless
you
and give you comfort during this
difficult
time mr speaker i yield back
for the purpose of the gentlewoman from
florida seek recognition
mr speaker i ask unanimous consent to
address the house for one minute and
revise and extend my remarks without
objection the gentlewoman is recognized
for one minute
thank you mr speaker i rise to honor a
fearless visionary woman who has
transcended generations with her legal
minds compassion and wit
as a jewish woman she was a personal
inspiration to me my daughters and
millions of others
who follow in her footsteps and are
guided by the same values of justice and
tikkun alam
in hebrew there is a saying may your
memory be for a revolution
and that aim is our promise to justice
ginsburg
around this country access to vital
reproductive health care is hanging on
by a thread
yesterday marks the 44th anniversary of
the hyde amendment
low-income women and women of color are
forced to make tough economic decisions
every day
that often put their own lives and that
of their families at risk before because
of their inability to access critical
family
planning justice ginsburg fought for
these women for all women
she was a tireless defender of our
nation's promise of freedom justice and
equality for all
yet with her passing we find ourselves
in a push to subvert reproductive rights
and dismantle health care protections
that 135 million people including me
with the pre-existing condition rely
upon justice ginsburg passed on heir of
rosh hashanah the start to the jewish
new year
they say that those who die on this day
are at static
or a person of righteousness ruth bader
ginsburg was certainly that
and more may justice ginsburg's memory
be for a blessing and her example
a righteous inspiration for us all thank
you i yield back the balance of my time
for what purposes gentleman from
washington seek recognition
mr speaker i request unanimous consent
to address the house for one minute
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute thank you mr
speaker today i rise in celebration of
his
hispanic heritage month in my home
district of central washington the
history and the culture
of hispanic americans woven into the
fabric of our communities
from small businesses in manufacturing
to agriculture
and artistry the success of our
communities is dependent
on the success of our diverse and
vibrant hispanic populations
earlier this year the house passed
legislation
to finally establish the national museum
of the american latino
in our nation's capital it is my hope
that this museum will empower
all of us to learn about and engage with
the history of hispanic americans
and their contributions to our history
and our culture
in central washington and across the
country we are proud of our
hispanic friends and neighbors who prove
that the american dream
is alive and well because of them we are
a
stronger more diverse more prosperous
society
and i urge my colleagues to join me in
celebrating hispanic heritage month
thank you mr speaker and i yield that
for what purpose does a gentleman from
texas seek recognition
hello mr speaker i asked consent dress
house for one minute advises 10
remarks without objection the gentleman
is recognized for one minute
mr speaker coveted 19 hit
fort bend county hard in march
our local concert venue the smart
financial center
has not rocked since yet fort bend
county
has rocked on the fort bend hope
clubhouse
kept rocking proof
rocks i received from their director
cary beth cunningham
we met monday back home she gave me
these two rocks with a common message
hashtag clubhouse rocks
texas they rock
because they're giving people mental
conditions the skills they need to build
confidence and independence members
choose
every day where they want to work work
in the kitchen
go to class clerical work technical work
or just outreach about the magic
happening
at the clubhouse keep
rocking fort bend hope clubhouse let's
walk into
mental health awareness week that starts
next week mahalo
i yield back
gentlewoman from texas seek recognition
mr speaker i asked to address the house
for one minute and revise and extend my
remarks
without objection the gentlewoman is
recognized for one minute
i want to take this time mr speaker to
not only speak to the american people
about
voting but just take a brief moment
to pay a beginning tribute
to justice ruth bader ginsburg she
deserves a much longer period of
acknowledgement
and i'm going to do so as we
return back to washington in the coming
days and weeks
in fact i believe that we should
dedicate weeks and days
of honoring justice ginsburg even in the
midst
of this potential nomination
to replace her but i wanted to speak to
the american people as we begin our
journey toward november 3rd and let them
know of the precious right to vote
that citizenship gives them that very
precious right to make their own
decision
i have no right to tell them that but as
a member of the united states congress i
have an obligation to ensure
that their vote is protected however
they vote
i must ensure that the mail ballots that
there is a truthful
understanding of mail balance some
states have been voting mail ballots for
decades i must ensure that the mail
ballots are protected
the early vote is protected and as well
it is protected on november 3rd i just
want to indicate
justice ginsburg said in the
shelby case that the majority's logic
was akin to throwing away your umbrella
in a rainstorm
because you're not getting wet she
believed in voting and voting protection
let's pay tribute to her and vote i
yield back
for what purpose does a gentleman from
pennsylvania seek recognition
mr speaker request unanimous consent to
address the house for one minute and
revise and extend my remarks
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute thank you mr
speaker
mr speaker last week i introduced hr
8332 the plugging or
orphan wells and environmental
restoration act or the power act
this bill would reauthorize the federal
orphan well remediation program under
the energy policy 2005
for five years of 50 million dollars per
year the power act would also establish
a grant program for environmental
restoration and reclamation of orphaned
wells
on state as well as private and tribal
lands authorized at 400 million dollars
per year for five years
it's estimated that pennsylvania has
more orphaned wells than any other state
pennsylvania is the birthplace of the
modern petroleum industry and the
commonwealth's oil gas industry
has helped lead america to energy
independence
we have both an economic and
environmental responsibility to ensure
abandoned
wells are plugged and the power act will
ensure these
legacy sites are appropriately handled
to protect the environment while also
stimulating jobs in the oil and gas
sector
this will be a win-win for america and a
win-win certainly for pennsylvania
i'd like to thank guy reidenthaler my
colleague from pennsylvania will be
for joining me on this legislation i
urge my colleagues to support oil and
gas well remediation
through the power act thank you mr
speaker and i yield back the balance of
my time
the chair lays before the house a
message
to the congress of the united states in
accordance with section 114 b
of division a of the continuing
appropriations act 2021
and other extensions act h.r 8337 the
act
i hereby designate for overseas
contingency
operations slash global war on terrorism
all funding
including the rescission of funds so
designated by the congress in the act
pursuant to section 251b
2a of the balanced budget and emergency
deficit control act of 1985
as outlined in the enclosed list of
accounts
the details of this action are set forth
in the enclosed memorandum
from the director of the office of
management and budget
signed sincerely donald john trump the
white house october 1st
2020 referred to the committee on
appropriations and ordered printed
the chair lays before the house a
message
to the congress of the united states in
accordance with section 114b
of division a of the continuing
appropriations act
2021 and other extensions act h.r 8337
the act
i hereby designate as emergency
requirements all funding including the
rescission of funds
so designated by the congressman act
pursuant to section 251b
2a of the balanced budget and emergency
deficit control act of 1985
as outlined in the enclosed list of
accounts the details of this action are
set forth in the enclosed memorandum
from the director of the office of
management and budget
signed sincerely donald john trump the
white house
october 1st 2020 referred to the
committee on appropriations and ordered
printed
the chair lays before the house of
communication
to the congress of the united states the
honorable the speaker house of
representatives madam
on september 30th 2020 pursuant to
section 3307 of title 40 united states
code
the committee on transportation and
infrastructure met an open session
to consider 33 resolutions included
in the general services administration's
capital investment and leasing programs
i have enclosed copies of the
resolutions adopted
signed sincerely peter defazio member of
congress
referred to the committee on
appropriations
under the speaker's announced policy of
january 3rd 2019
the gentleman from arkansas mr west
westerman
is recognized until 10 pm as a designee
of the minority leader
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i ask
unanimous consent that all members may
have five legislative days in which to
revise and extend the remarks and
include extraneous material
on the topic of the special order
without objection
mr speaker fires are ravaging the west i
want to talk a little bit about
what's going on with the fires and i
want to talk about what's not going on
here in congress to start with i just
want to take a quick look at the science
of fire
this fire triangle shows that three
things are required to have a fire you
have to have fuel
heat and oxygen there's a lot of talk
about what
the role climate change is playing in
these fires
climate increasing temperatures can draw
fuel
uh if it gets windy you can have more
oxygen lightning can be one of the
things to ignite fires but a lot of
fires obviously are
ignited by man-made ways
when we talk about putting out fire the
first thing we do is try to get the fuel
out of the way
or we use water to cool the
cool the fire and remove the oxygen but
we have to spend way too much time
working on extinguishing fires when we
could take the actions to reduce the
fuel to reduce the fires
anytime i talk about forest management
i get accused of wanting to clear cut
the national forest and i can promise
you the last thing i want to do is
clear-cut the national forest i want to
use good
management on the national forest that's
what we should be doing
but i often wonder if those people who
talk about clear cutting even have any
idea what a clear cut is
i've put this chart together that shows
a comparison between a clear cut
and a catastrophic wildfire and i'll go
on the record and say that catastrophic
wildfires are worse than clear cuts
and look at the data during a clear-cut
the trees are killed during a
catastrophic wildfire the trees are
killed
during a clear-cut the trees are removed
during a catastrophic wildfire you're
left with dead snags that can be
fueled for additional wildfires all
vegetation is killed that's what happens
in a catastrophic wildfire at least in a
clear cut you leave the residual grasses
and the shrubs
stream zones are protected when a clear
cut is done you leave
vegetation around the streams
catastrophic wildfire burns to the edge
of the water
soil organic materials are all burned up
in a catastrophic wildfire special care
is taken to protect the soil
in a clear cut when a clear-cut is
planned
a plan for reforestation is also in
place
often on catastrophic wildfire there is
no reforestation
as far as planning goes it's extensive
with a clear-cut it's unplanned and
uncontrolled in a catastrophic wildfire
the size of a clear-cut in california
it's less than 20 acres
wildfires are huge burning millions of
acres we've almost burned eight million
acres
to date uh in the wildfire season this
year in the u.s
and we can continue going down the list
but you can see
even talking about carbon um
at least with a clear cut you're putting
the wood into a material that stores
carbon the wildfire you're leasing
releasing the carbon into the air and
these dead snags eventually rot
and they're not just releasing carbon
dioxide like the fire does
they're releasing methane which is the
worst greenhouse gas
clear cutting is not something that we
want to do on the national forest
but people who are not allowing good
forest management and that's congress
with the rules that we have are doing
something much more devastating than
clear cutting
by allowing these catastrophic wildfires
to continue
unabated
just as an example this is the angora
fire
that is a natural clear cut that's a
stand replacing fire this is 12 years
later
where you have no regrowth on the site
on top of that according to the usgs in
2018
the carbon emissions from wildfires
released the same amount of carbon
as the emissions that would be produced
by generating enough electricity to
power california for a whole year
mr speaker we need to take action it's
not that the forest service doesn't know
how to manage the land it's that we have
tied their hands
and we've allowed activists and lawyers
to manage the forest rather than the
professionals in the forest service
if we don't want to see the same things
repeating over and over
with loss of life loss of property
loss of a resource that actually pulls
carbon dioxide out of the air and can be
used to reduce
uh the effects of climate we should do
something proactive and actually start
managing these forests
it's time to act and unfortunately
congress has set on our hands while we
continue to watch the west
burn that i would like to yield four
minutes to the gentleman from arizona mr
gosar
first of all i'd like to thank my friend
from arkansas mr westerman for
organizing this special
order and for his leadership and
expertise on forestry issues
the events of the last month in the last
decade plus show how
how poorly our current forest management
policies
are and that they're broken in a drastic
need of reform
nearly every corner of the west has been
touched by catastrophic wildfire
my district has been home to several
major fires this year including the bush
fire
that burned over 193 thousand acres and
700 thousands of acres of land in
arizona have been
burned across my state even before this
year's fire season broke
the evidence of our forest management
practices are clearly
broken in the last 10 years alone
wildfires have burned over 74 million
acres of land in the west and our
federal government reaction to this has
been extremely lacking
these catastrophic fires have
devastating impacts on environment and
health for example one large wildfire is
roughly the equivalent of a major
volcanic eruption
religion releasing a large amount of
dangerous particles into the air
this increase in air pollution
exacerbates respiratory illnesses
such as covid19 because of this earlier
this year i led a letter to the arc
the agriculture secretary perdue and
interior secretary bernhard
this letter urged them to act quickly to
secure contracts with private businesses
to ensure that firefighters could be
properly protected from covet 19
and that the aerial support they needed
to adequately fight catastrophic pilot
was there
recent studies conducted at george mason
university showed that on average a fire
stands a higher probability of being
contained within 24 hours if air tankers
are deployed
on that fire within the first few hours
fires that do not receive
air tanker support for a period of 13
hours or more are likely to take
days or weeks to achieve containment i
also led a letter to our attorney
general barr that urged him to ensure
that the justice department's natural
resources division was adequately
resourced
to fight frivolous lawsuits from radical
left-wing environmental organizations
lawsuits are from radical
environmentalists are nothing new
we have seen this already in arizona
with the disastrous wilder
wild earth guardian lawsuit regarding
the mexican spotted owl
in that case the u.s district court
judge in tucson issued a ruling based on
bad and debunked science
that stopped active force management
activities in six
national forests including the tonto
national forest in arizona
which was home to the bushfire this
decision was a massive setback and it's
directly contributing to the enhanced
fire risk
that threatens our communities that
we're seeing across the west
a devastating wildfire season is not
inevitable it isn't something that we
must just accept there are steps that
can be taken now to ensure that our
communities are protected
i continue to urge the federal agencies
to take to
be tasked with managing our forest fires
and fighting catastrophic fires
and with bold action that is necessary
lives depend upon it
just last year as chairman of the
congressional western caucus i had the
opportunity to visit with the district
of my friend from california
mr mcclintock where aggressive forest
management practices in lake tahoe basin
have prevented catastrophic fire this
active management was made possible by
getting unnecessary red tape out of the
way and putting what is most important
to
first protecting our communities from
the destruction of wildfire
just in the last two years this
administration has taken steps to manage
vegetation inside
utility corridors build additional fire
breaks and reform the nepa process
within the forest service
however so many years of inaction
there's a long road to ho
to where we have to get which is why i'm
so pleased we're here tonight
calling for serious action by this house
there's a few pieces of legislation that
have been introduced i just want to name
a few
h.r 7978 a bipartisan comprehensive
forestry
reform bill led by the gentleman from
california mr lamalfa
this as well as h.r 2607 the resilient
federal forest
acts by mr westman both of which i'm
proud to support the democratic
leadership in this house has been
transparent about the fact that they do
not view forest management
to prevent wildfires as a legislative
priority
and that has deadly consequences again i
want to thank my friend from arkansas
for holding the special order
and with his leadership and expertise on
this issue and i yield back to him thank
the gentleman from arizona and i
recognize the gentleman from washington
mr newhouse for three minutes
thank you to my good friend from
arkansas mr westerman
as we all know the west has been on fire
in my home state of washington
over seven hundred thousand acres have
burned causing thousands of families to
evacuate
leaving their homes their businesses and
their farms behind
whole towns have essentially been wiped
off the map
smoke blanketed central washington with
fires
raging up and down the west coast the
air quality of our cities and our rural
areas
ranks ranked the worst in the world
as the people of central washington and
many of my colleagues in congress
understand healthy resilient forests are
the key to wildfire prevention
we've made significant progress but
there's still much work to be done
without our leadership in congress
families will continue
to lose their homes and their businesses
and jobs will continue to be lost
and our public health will continue to
be threatened
and while the loss of homes and
livelihoods is heartbreaking there's
nothing
more tragic tragic than the loss of life
today i joined the people of central
washington in mourning
the loss of one-year-old baby highland
whose life was tragically cut short as
his parents
fled to escape the cold springs fire
that was raging across
okanagan county the highland family
has suffered a measurable loss with the
deaths of both
their toddler as well as the death of
their unborn
child my heart aches and my prayers go
out for the highlands as they recover
from their own wounds in this
unimaginable
heartbreak these tragic circumstances
fall on us mr speaker
we are responsible as the federal
government for failing
to deliver a management strategy that
enables us to prevent
these catastrophic events we cannot
continue to sit idly by we have
to responsibly log our force and graze
our lands
or we will watch them burn these
wildfires and this year have
truly tested our resilience but of this
i am certain
in the face of catastrophe central
washington will recover
now it is the federal government's
responsibility to do everything
in its power to prevent another disaster
like this again
thank you mr westerman thank the
gentleman from washington and now you
yield three minutes to the gentleman
from alabama mr palmer
i thank the gentleman from arkansas for
holding this
discussion about forest management and
mr speaker i rise
today because california's four suffer
from neglect and mismanagement
resulting in overcrowding that leaves
them susceptible
to disease insects and wildfire these
are not my words
they're the words of the little hoover
commission an independent state
oversight agency in california
in their 2018 report entitled fire on
the mountain
the little hoover commission called for
a transformational change in california
forest management practices
after a century of mismanaging sierra
nevada forest
has brought an unprecedented
environmental catastrophe
that impacts all californians that's a
direct quote from the report
california's own legislative analyst
office agreed and found that limitations
on timber harvesting
an emphasis on fire suppression and an
increasing number of environmental
permitting requirements
have led to unhealthily dense forests
thankfully both groups recognize that
common sense forest management practices
could not only help prevent wildfires
but also reduce carbon emissions
properly managed and healthy forests are
more resilient and sequester more carbon
than overgrown forest simple
recommendations like shifting from fire
suppression
to using fire as a tool and setting up
long-term forest management strategies
are just a couple of the low-cost
solutions that can help us achieve
healthier forests
unlike policies such as the green new
deal these practices would actually help
address
wildfires and would not cost trillions
of dollars to implement
furthermore these actions can all be
taken today and they fall in line
with some of the things that my
republican colleagues and i
have been suggesting on the select
committee on the climate crisis
that if we take action to mitigate and
adapt to the climate change that we know
is going to occur we could avoid some of
the catastrophes that we're seeing
playing out in california right now and
in other places
in the west if you care about protecting
our citizens from wildfires and reducing
carbon emissions then you should support
responsible forest management instead of
wasting time on unrealistic solutions
we should take serious action to prevent
unnecessary wildfires
and improve the carbon sequestration
potential of our forest
i yield back the balance of my time
thank the gentleman from alabama and i
recognize the gentleman from
pennsylvania mr thompson for two minutes
i thank the gentleman from arkansas for
hosting this special order on wildfire
mr speaker over the past decade there's
been an average of 64
100 wildfires and 6.8 million acres
burned
every year with over 10 million acres
burned we saw the highest number of
federal acres
burned in 2015 and that and nearly that
amount in 2017
but this year has been even worse 2020
has been an extremely difficult wildfire
year for our firefighters our responders
and many rural communities in and near
the forests as of today october
1st over 44 000 wildfires have burned
nearly 7.7
million acres this year alone in
addition to the destruction of these
forests
homes and property we sadly continue to
see lost lives
over the past 25 years active management
has plummeted across the national forest
system
consequently is no coincidence that the
larger and more intense fires are
happening on federal lands
where there is less management versus
state and private lands
more individual fires occur in the east
but the wildfires in the west are larger
and burn more acres
wildfires also have significant impacts
on eastern forests
because the budgetary effects on forest
service ability
to manage and personnel we must be
encouraged
encouraging more active forest
management across the national forest
system
this includes thinning prescribed fires
and hazardous fuels reduction
especially on the roughly 90 million
acres of federal lands
that are already known to be at high
risk i thank my colleague mr westerman
for his great work during the last farm
bill
and his leadership with the resilient
federal forest act and the trillion
trees act
through the next farm bill i'm hopeful
that we will can continue to build on
these common-sense reforms
that will provide more authorities to
help the forest service better manage
and encourage more partnerships with
that i yield back
i thank the gentleman from pennsylvania
and mr speaker i just want to illustrate
here that this isn't difficult it's not
rocket science this is
a control in the first picture you see
all the underbrush
the ladder fuels this is on federal land
as well
you see the the forest management in the
middle where you thin it out you do
control
burns you do those every few years and
you get a resilient forest that looks
like this
california and oregon and arizona and
washington state
nevada they could have forests that
looked like this now they would be those
species that are out there and the
management will be accordingly
but there's no reason we can't do this
it's speaker pelosi's state that's on
fire
it's chairman grijalva's state that's on
fire it's chairman defazio's state
that's on fire
i wish that democrats would take time
to do what's right to address these
fires to quit having
playing politics with relief bills that
are going nowhere and do something that
could really help the people in their
states
we want to help but we can't do it on
our own we're in the minority
we will work together and offer
suggestions but it takes
it's going to take a bipartisan effort
to change these rules so that management
can take place
i yield back
pursuant to section 4b of house
resolution 967
the house stands adjourned until nine
a.m tomorrow
i